il ya deux semaines j'ai recueilli un
chat la spa en effet une petite vidéo et
franchement je pensais pas que cette
adoption marquerait autant les gens
merlin a eu le droit à des articles dans
google à paris match la voix du nord le
new york times bon ok pas le tight ça
j'ai inventé et puis beaucoup d'entre
vous m'ont simplement demandé en
commentaire une vidéo où je vous
présente merlin avec plaisir enfin s'il
veut bien
merlin voilà le tournage est interrompu
parce que l'un des acteurs refusent de
jouer
vous avez deviné qui sait il s'agit de
merlin qu'actuellement et dans une sorte
de petit tunnel
je ne peux pas aller évidemment mais à
l' énorme alors il a l'air heureux comme
ça pourtant la loi elle a un passé
plutôt tristounet l'histoire de merlin
tout commence en 2016 quand un habitant
de la ville de saint-omer est alerté par
des miaulements détresse provenant d'un
logement inhabitée depuis des mois
apparemment les anciens propriétaires
ont abandonné la maison avec leurs cinq
chars l'intérieur sans doute des frères
et soeurs le riverain alors contacté une
équipe de la spa qui est venu
s'introduire dans le domicile abandonné
mais malheureusement sur les cinq chars
quatre sont retrouvés morts le seul
survivant
c'est merlin il a finalement atterri à
la spa d'état londres où j'ai recueilli
peu vu son passé douloureux
là quand je laisse tout seul parce que
je vais dormir j'ai toujours peur qu'il
croit que je l'abandonnent comme ses
anciens maîtres meyrin ge et abandonne
pas là je vais me coucher
arrêtons regarder comme ça je vais juste
me coucher je reviens après je dors une
nuit
[Musique]
ouais merlin a donc deux ans il mesure
42 cm de long 30 cm de haut il est noir
au dessus
lanzhou grandes chaussettes à l'arrière
petit à l'avant moustache blanche les
yeux cas qui comme moi je sois un
certain angle il pourrait faire penser à
un pingouin ou un chat en smoking qui
porterait une cagoule il a encore un peu
de mal à faire confiance aux humains
voilà pourquoi la première fois où j'ai
lâché dans mon appart
il a disparu le plus vite possible
bienvenue dans ton nouveau chez toi et
je peux vous dire que quand un chat
décide de se cacher ils se cachent dans
des endroits de la maison que tu
n'imaginais même pas j'avais pas qu'il y
avait un trou dans ce mur à meyrin et
puis au bout de plusieurs heures
d'attentes au fond d'un trou sous la
baignoire
c'est vrai que merlin attend la
baignoire enfin ils adorent être en
dessous pas trop dedans surtout le
prochain tube à sèmèrè j'ai peur j'ai
tenté la même chose avec le lavabo
[Musique]
donc toi tu pars au moment où le lavabo
et rempli quoi bien gelée au jeu j'ai
toujours vécu avec des chats noirs dans
ma vie j'ai dû en avoir au moins une
dizaine
d'ailleurs faut avouer que merlin il
ressemble un petit peu à cergy on dirait
qu'on a copié collé la tête de cergy sur
merlin
c'est peut-être sa réincarnation bon
comme tous les chats merlin son petit
côté de fil ou un comme par exemple
merlin ou le chat extrêmement crâne
minutes hier franche a complètement
craqué ça marche pas mal à ok en tout
cas maintenant il semble super heureux
c'est vraiment une machine à fond pour
faire rhône et il suffit de poser sa
main dessus
il est joueur il fait des câlins il
adore me dire bonjour avec son anus un
vrai plaisir
je crois qu'il est heureux d'avoir enfin
trouvé un maître qui donne pleins
d'amour tellement heureux qui me suit à
peu près partout tout le temps
[Musique]
en tout cas ça me fait plaisir d'avoir
retrouvé une petite boule de poils noirs
j'avais oublié tous ces petits moments
cool ou marrant qu'un chat peut nous
faire vivre voilà si vous voulez suivre
ses aventures et ben abonnez vous à ma
chaîne au revoir
[Musique]